[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation
I'm your host on sakyo now we're sitting
down with Tony Chen from prime VAX are
you doing thank you for coming on the
show yeah thank you for having me pretty
pleasure yeah I love what you're doing
with the the public intellectual trying
to get more people excited about
changing the world thank you my man
thank you and we got you on the show
talking about cancer cures yeah yeah
definitely an exciting time for us and
definitely an exciting time for the
industry very very happy to kind of give
like an overview of what the entire
cancer treatment space looks like where
we fit into it as well as what some of
the other players in the space are doing
for which there are many yeah biotechs
exploding right now oh my god and
everybody is it's very relatable to
people when it comes to people's health
because they want to know how they can
live longer healthier all that kind of
jazz so that's probably the most
applicable but so wait wait a second
before we get into that cuz I think it's
really important but why do you care
about biotech and how'd you pick this
cancer how'd you pick that yeah you know
it's funny actually um so I felt into
the pharma and biotech world right out
of college study the econ in undergrad
didn't really do any real science but
then you know all my clients when I was
a strategy and a management consultant
they were drug companies however the
years I learned the industry just by the
simple fact that I was working in this
space for this time and then a bunch of
my friends started developing cancer not
a good look I want to do something about
it and at the time you know rewind the
clock maybe like five years ago I was
doing strategy consulting work for drug
companies you know like the
bristol-myers Squibb of the world the
you know what the thiser is like those
general you know pharma companies
helping them launch drugs setting prices
looking at how do you actually get the
drug correctly placed on to insurance
formularies for example and you know I
just thought that the industry wasn't
really like it was making some amazing
advancements but if you were to look at
some of the objective data coming out of
those clinical trials or some of those
data sets they weren't like too amazing
you know you might be looking at one out
of five patients cured effectively in
melanoma for example but those are still
relatively low numbers so one of these
smaller biotechs with whom we were
talking you know how can we get it's a
five out of five cured you know what man
that's what we're heading I think that
that's exactly where the industry needs
to go we are doing our best to you know
play a role in that process really
excited about it but the biotech science
team came to me five years ago and they
had this very very novel new idea for
cancer treatment completely the exact
opposite treatment modality as every
other drug company or drug you know
development process and I said Wow
like looking at this from a strategy
perspective looking at what drugs are
actually you know going through the
process of being launched and being paid
for being reimbursed covered you know
for insurance you know you'll go to a
hospital now you can just get these new
drugs that are already available
commercially looking at those drugs and
seeing you know where their limitations
are scientifically and looking at where
these guys could be actually really
changing the game I said I had to get
involved what is what does that look
like for once they once you pass Mouse
trials yep then you go to clinical
trials with humans and then once you go
through clinical trials then you have to
have a certain threshold you have to
meet that criteria yeah and then you go
into actual sales and distribution and
and when you do sales and distribution
you have to figure out how to work with
insurance yep if to figure out all that
stuff before you can actually get a
a doctor yeah that is in immuno
oncologist to prescribe you with a
cancer exactly and so and so then most
of these drugs are cost like millions
and millions of dollars to go through
that process
yep the Rd the Rd is very expensive yeah
and then so usually there's an outside
company that's funding that process cuz
it's hard for average Joe yep to be like
to build a drug to build a cancer drug
absolutely yeah yeah yeah so I can talk
to that a little bit you're absolutely
right you begin first with Mouse data
once you generate that and once you
think that that looks good you submitted
to FDA and then you begin the clinical
trial process typically follows three
phases phase 1 phase 2 you and then
phase 3 every step of the process you're
generating more and more data it's more
statistically significant you can run
analyses on patients subpopulations or
mechanisms of action or what have you
and as you mentioned you know toward the
end of like the phase 3 time frame is
really where the rubber meets the road
and you need to demonstrate real actual
efficacy meaning statistically
significant directly you know
head-to-head ideally with a comparator
arm with whatever the current standard
of care is to show that you know cancer
patients are currently being treated at
this amount with this level of response
and now we with our new drug are coming
in with this much better of a response
rate yeah for example and then you
submit that to the FDA FDA looks at that
and says yep this looks good or no this
doesn't come back with more data yeah
ideally you do that process you get that
done and then after that then you turn
into the full commercial yeah stage yeah
now it's interesting that you mentioned
you know like the the the
commercialization aspect of it and
needing a larger external company to
help do the sales and distribution right
the funny thing is that you know for us
where we came from or where I used to
come from as a strategy consultant is
that we would have to do this a lot
earlier in the process than you think
your commercial strategy for launching
the drug kinda already needs to be
like built out and formulated during
your phase one human trial and ideally
you should be kind of building that into
your earlier mouse models and other
petri dish in vitro type experiments
when you already have in mind what the
future of the actual commercial
applicability is going to be but it's
hard to assess the money into that if
you haven't gotten the FDA approval like
oh yeah go so some people are worried
that they would invest money in that and
then not even get approved yep which is
understandable but the same time than if
you're building out that model and gives
you a better understanding of what your
drugs going to look like as an impact
actual world outside of these mouse
trials and clinical trial it's funny I
think that many many people in the
health care space are very micro focused
or laser focus on that specific segment
of their development some people in drug
companies only do early clinical some
people are only commercial people some
people are only regulatory affairs you
know like and they do nothing else but
that but I think for me at least where I
come from and my entire like world view
on this drug development process and
said you kind of need to know where
you're going when you're much earlier
which we are yeah but you know
thankfully we're about to enter human
phase one trials but around the corners
yeah it's a it's an exciting time yeah
yeah exactly so now the body is so
complex there's so many different ways
for the body to get disease and then
also combat disease yep so there's you
know some very simple way of
understanding this with maybe your
you're getting a flu yep you get the flu
and then within a couple days your
immune system fights off the flu that's
right and then you're good to go
but there are other times when your
cells become cancerous cells and that
causes your immune system tries to fight
that's right and these are called
t-cells that are these among many others
but yes many other cells that try and go
and fight that's right against cancer
and
then they have difficulty targeting the
cancer cells because they don't
necessarily the cancer cells are like
camouflaged that's right the other cells
and so it's difficult for them to find
them and kill them and so then this is a
very interesting way to try and leverage
the human body to be able to identify
those cancer cells and kill them so we
can live a little bit healthier for
longer so what is exactly how did you
discover this process at prime VAX how
are you really incorporating the t-cell
absolutely yes no thanks so much Alan
now I love the fact that you or you're
actually incredibly well read up on the
topic so okay love it okay right I love
it I love it because a lot of people
when they talk about cancer I think they
speak in terms of vague conceptual ideas
of what it is but when you actually get
down to like the self specific type
interactions or you know how the immune
system relates to the cancer cells for
example and how that interaction occurs
the combating the constant cat-and-mouse
game like the fact that you're diving
into the detailed level I love it so you
know our company the idea behind it is
very very simple reprogram your immune
system from the ground up to basically
be remember or to be what it always was
before you actually had cancer to begin
with and you need to basically crash and
reboot the entire immune system to do
that that's the overarching idea so what
we do is first we have to do what's
called a dendritic cell vaccine these
have been tried in the industry many
people have actually done this for uh
you know a decade or two what is a
dendritic cell a dendritic cell is one
of your main immune cells in your body
right now you might say what is it it's
in your blood so my blood yep it is
basically is this smaller than a red
blood cell
it's a white blood cell it's a literally
is a white blood cell so a dendritic
cell is a white blood cell yep so
basically there's like what is it five
times less white blood cells and red
blood cells or even less than that oh
that bad question is above my pay grade
but there are a lot there are left right
yeah yeah generally speaking you don't
need that many dendritic cells in the
body compared
you know red blood cells which might you
know deliver more nutrients or what have
you
your dendritic cells are there to keep
you safe they're there to act as the
primary Scouter or Scout cells of your
immune system yes anytime that your body
you know find something wrong and then
it you know like tries to induce some
sort of an immunological response that's
your dendritic cell working so the
easiest example I can think of to show
people is suppose you know like I'm
gonna roll up my sleeve for a moment
here right supposed to have I were to
just press and you know kind of flick my
you know wrist a little bit right yeah
scratch it up get it all bruised up
right yeah and you know we'll just keep
talking for a little bit but when we
come back to it a couple of seconds
later you'll notice that you know my
wrist is starting to turn red right yeah
so that's basically like an inflammatory
response and then later on your
dendritic cells were actually go there
find what happened and then communicate
back in your lymph nodes and talk to
your t-cells and say you know what there
were bad signals here something funny is
going on go there and kill whatever you
think looks bad and here's what the
information looks like that you know is
relevant to you know the bad damaged
cells and there's a certain there's a
certain list of inventory that they have
that they know of what is what
constitutes being bad exactly and
they've identified that by physically
going there surveying it and then going
back to the lymph nodes and telling the
t-cells that that's basically what the
process is so they have to take it they
take a step through the lymph nodes
before communicating the T cells
well the Lucas lymph nodes they
circulate the white blood cells what do
they do with the way blows notes are
basically one of your primary immune
functions in your entire body like you
have lymph nodes throughout your entire
body right yes yes it's where a lot of
your T cells reside actually okay so you
can think of them as like the police
depots in your immune system meant to go
and you know like wouldn't the dendritic
cells go to them the T cells that are
sitting there in dormant status reawaken
based on the information that the
dendritic cells provide the T cells and
the T cells say hey there is something
bad going on here you've given me the
information now let me go to that
location and kill whatever that actual
thing
you gave me holy s--t depos is so funny
and then they're the police cars that go
out that's literally it and they have
they have a list you know based on what
the dendritic cells provide them you
know the dendritic cell says oh this
looks like a bruised skin cell it's in
this general location of this arm so
that my t-cells are probably right now
going via my bloodstream to go to where
that location is and trying to find
whatever the damaged cells are and kill
them so that's how your normal body
functions and you and I knock on wood
are you know pretty young and dumb and
we don't have cancer thankfully to our
knowledge right now right but for a
cancer patient that entire process I
described has already failed them and
that's where we come in that's what we
think about in order for which part the
police Depot the communication of the
police Depot all of those notes all of
it there is some sort of a failure in
the entire systemic process okay so
basically once the T cells go there and
kill the bad cells right then the
healthy cells surrounding it are saying
well okay there's some left over space
let me fill that in with healthy cells
again and then macrophages and other
immune cells come in and gobble up the
dead cells the T cells killed that were
damaged and that's what cell cycle
rejuvenation is that like as one
archetypal example like that's how your
body stays healthy right now so for a
cancer patient you know for the in order
for like a cancer lesion or a tumor to
exist in the body in that particular
location what that means is that that
entire process because it's one big loop
somewhere in that process something was
disrupted and most of the time it's
probably in a couple of different places
that this is that this disruption
happened so I'll give you an example as
you mentioned you know like cancer cells
are really good at evading and hiding
from the immune system right a cancer
cell might pump out a a protein called
tgf-beta and the tgf-beta will literally
act as like an in and like an
invisibility cloak it'll basically hide
that cancer cell from the immune system
when the T cell comes there knowing the
actual correct information of what that
cancer cell looks like because your
dendritic cell already
found it went back to the T cell the T
cell said oh I'm ready to go I'm gonna
go there and kill it
T cell gets there the tgf-beta puts the
T cell to sleep and then the T cell
can't do the killing so you have a whole
bunch of T cells sitting around either
sleeping napping on the job or what have
you
right next to the tumor and in fact
those T cells are what we call in the
industry immunosuppressed T cells
immunosuppressed yeah yep so our so what
in the so that that protein causes the T
cell to fall asleep on the job they sit
right next to the tumor yep and that's
so shitty that really they're right next
to it yeah I mean it's not like it goes
back and the gun is loaded with the
pre-program bullet to actually kill that
T that cancer cell the T cell is ready
to pull the trigger and then all of a
sudden yeah it just doze off right and
if that's the case you know you're in in
that scenario right your immune system
has failed you because the tgf-beta
pumped out by the cancer cell has
overcome the stimulation the immuno
stimulation or immuno activation status
of the T cells going there
so our entire approach is to say let's
disrupt all that and let's make the
tumor microenvironment Reese simulated
again but first we have to begin by
making the dendritic cells do what they
were supposed to do so another example
in this entire process is that you know
sometimes your dendritic cells are not
able to find the actual cancer
information mm-hmm so remember the
latter example we mentioned was tgf-beta
right the T cell goes there can't kill
the cancer cell well it could fail
earlier in the process as well
your dendritic cell goes there tries to
find they can't the the cancer cell
doesn't find anything more it that may
be the tgf-beta or any of the other
proteins that the cancer pumps out might
cause it's to evade the dendritic cell
itself then the dendritic cell never
actually picked up the information or
the dendritic cell picked up the
information correctly but then was also
switched into immunosuppressed status as
well so when they go back to the police
depots in the lymph nodes right and then
they talk to the T cells they tell the T
cell well here's the information
but don't really bother like you're
going there and killing them too hard
there okay so the cancer cell basically
tricked the dendritic cell in that
scenario - not really relay the correct
you know killing signal information to
the T cell then the T cell itself learns
the immunosuppressed you know
personality type or you know whatever
analogy you want to use of that
dendritic cell that was also kind of you
know like immunosuppressed and then when
the T cell goes back there it doesn't
really have any motivation to actually
kill the cancer cell either so there's
multiple failures in the entire you know
like cancer like carcinogenesis slash
you know cancer growing process that
your immune system has failed you on so
we first have to make sure that the
dendritic cells from the get-go are
programmed correctly so for us what we
do is we're gonna take a sample of the
patient's own tumors via a biopsy and a
sample of the patients blood and from
the blood will isolate the white blood
cells which contain the dendritic cells
and we're actually getting basically
like what are called immature dendritic
cells you can think of them as just baby
dendritic cells and we do a process and
when you get those all the way through
their 70s or 80s you exact always
dendritic cells your body always has to
endure it excels any does not happen in
these nascent and dendritic cells yes
their early stage ones yep you're you're
so basically as part of dendritic cell
growth they begin as what are called
monocytes and then as they grow into you
know adulthood they turn into one of two
things dendritic cells or macrophages
dendritic cells are the Scout cells that
we described macrophages you can think
of them as the easiest analogy is like
they're kind of like pac-man they just
gobble up whatever damaged
you know like ghost type cells that are
sitting there if you have some sort of a
damaged signal like for example when I
bruised my skin earlier and the
macrophage is what comes here chews up
and you know basically eats up the other
damaged cells and then goes on their
merry way so your white blood cells
those baby monocytes can be one of those
two things our process is we have a leaf
skew your monocytes toward the dendritic
cell class
and we pump them full of as much immuno
stimulation as we can while we put them
in the presence of the cancer
information that we got from the tumor
biopsy because we're literally
surgically removing a beam of the
patient's tumor yeah grinding that up
and then when you grind that up the
tumor cells release their antigen or
cell ID information yeah they must as
part of their dying you know the
dendritic cells see that pick it up and
are basically matured in the presence of
what we think is probably one of the
best immunostimulant cocktails in the
industry and obviously you know part of
that is our own internal know-how and
patents and so on and so forth but what
we end up with is within less than a
week of basically little vials of
finished dendritic cell product that are
matured that are fully recognized the
patient's own full personalized cancer
information they can get past that
protein inside beta tgf-beta inside of
the tumor that's that's repelling away
that's we think so there is okay that's
what we need to prove exactly cool the
preclinical data have a leaf suggest
that we think that it should do that but
at the end of the day you know where I
come from I think that you know human
data is always the gold standard the
longhouse matters I love how you
mentioned you gave the story of how you
take the cancer biopsy and then you
grind it up yep so that way you get the
cell ID that's a really good way to say
and then if you like you said if you're
skewing all more of the dendron and more
dendritic cells from the yep from the
baby white blood cell then you can even
boost it up further into a state of
immune prosperity absolutely and then
that makes it even easier to combat
potentially so this sounds very
promising okay and then it's a good next
step into dengue or should we wait yeah
absolutely
so basically if we let's assume that
we've done the hypothesis correctly that
we've built a very
good immuno stimulated dendritic cell
product that is able to actually
recognize all the cancer that the
patient has right so now if you think
about it that means that specificity of
the patient's own tumors has now been
correctly re-established in the body
when we put those back in and then it is
edge north through a normal blood
injection
we'll do it via an intravenous infusion
ingenious effusion one-timer through a
couple days or that really depends on
the clinical trial design but it will be
either one time or two times or four
times depending on the specific arm of
the hypothesis we are testing okay cool
so part of that is going to be
understanding the schedule and
understanding the schedule is literally
what you do as part of you know running
a clinical trial but the hypotheses are
laid out there so that we can do it over
you know like a week or up to two months
for example so suppose we've done that
right well at that point you also still
need have another questions so how long
would it take until you've administered
that intravenously to know if it has
worked yes so we're gonna basically give
the patient about a month and a half
before we do their pet and their CT
scans yeah
and that's when we actually get the
first real response data now that said
you could start working on it right away
absolutely but exactly for but for
actually taking a whole bunch of cancer
cells yeah that might take a couple of
weeks yeah but it might start working on
it right away
yeah so in fact it's interesting Alan I
I love the fact that you're actually
drilling into this because what you're
describing is what we call in the
medical industry as you don't want to
have what's called a false positive too
early oh yeah
so sometimes one of the main issues that
immunotherapy drugs run into is that
because their entire premise is that
they're working on actually stimulating
the immune system to overcome cancer
right and kill it sometimes if you take
a pet or a CT scan too early you might
be picking up a false positive in which
you've seen the cancer actually growing
more and what so because what you're
going to be doing before you give the
patient the treatment is you're gonna do
a pet and a CT scan right you have to
first see how much tumor is in them
before yeah and then how much tumor is
in them
well yeah if they're after a picture is
measured too early you might actually
read out a whole bunch of t-cells and a
whole bunch of other immune cells going
in and doing their job fighting the war
against the cancer cell in that region
right in which case that skin might come
back and say actually no your tumor grew
but that's a false reading so you
actually want to give the immune system
a little bit more time to actually get
them to go back to homeostatic control
for example go back to more of a
baseline level and then do the correct
skin and then that's interesting and
that's usually about four to six weeks
would give it enough time I think so
and then yeah what would the the pet or
the CT scan what does that look like for
for imaging what is the type of imaging
that's used is it electromagnetic how is
it how does it actually know and again
that's a question beyond my paygrade as
well an approximation
I mean basically all I know from it I'm
not a radiologist I'm a business guy and
but what I do know about you know the
entire imaging process is that basically
they just shoot a bunch of lights into
you
the lights are specifically looking for
certain you know like mass is based on
certain markers or what-have-you and
then those things are going to be the
thing that you do and to establish the
baseline and then you do the exact same
measurement again for a post treatment
yeah and so then the lights are then
trying to find the masses and different
masses of different cells and yeah and
then now tell you what kind of cells are
there and so certain cancer cells have a
so different mast
I think so okay yeah interesting okay
well well I want to dig dig into that
more that's more of an education for me
as well good great yeah we all are
slowly learning this stuff okay
absolutely all right so so yeah where
are we now yeah so now at this point
let's assume I've gotten the specificity
down well you have to understand from
our perspective you know like where we
think about cancer patients is that if
you are already a late stage cancer
patient and that's the patient
population we're going after we want to
treat patients who have already failed
other treatments for whom those other
treatments have failed why not treat
people that earlier the
have the very very first signs we would
love to but you know this is actually
part of a regulation team and we're
successful with the very first signs you
know everybody tells us that Alan you're
absolutely right oh man I would love to
treat earlier cancer patients and we
will we'll get there but from a
regulatory strategy perspective only let
you test people that have failed
everything yeah and the reason for that
well I wouldn't say they only let you
but your regulatory Road when you deal
with the FDA or any government agency
and I used to work in the Department of
Health and Human Services I can tell you
this you want to play the game according
to the rules defined in the industry and
their rules are they think of as number
one there's already standard of care out
there for you know decently late stage
cancer oh sure those are well understood
and well studied with many many other
clinical trials versus your new stuff
exactly impair yeah so you and so what
you really need to show is basically for
the patients who failed those ones do
you add something else for the process
yeah do you really push the needle
forward a little bit yeah and if you do
you honestly you're like I do yeah
exactly yeah
they'll let you in and from a pure
humanity perspective right if you want
to think about this as a humanitarian
effort which I think is really important
with you cancer the bottom line is that
you know any movement that you make for
a non responding patient population
means that the entire cancer patient
population is benefited definitely right
and you want that you want as much
coverage as you can possibly get for as
many people as you can so we'll begin
with late stage we treat those patients
and then we slowly work our way back in
time yep but to answer your question if
we're going after late stage cancer
patients like right now in the very very
short term running this clinical trial
well those patients have been already
hammered by many other drugs
chemotherapy other immune therapies
their patient you know like their white
blood cell counts might just be lower
for example their immune statuses are
weaker than you or I are right now they
need something like a kick in the pants
basically to reinvigorate their immune
system
to a much higher activated status level
so if we've defined the specificity
using the dendritic cells we need to
have something that greatly stimulates
the immune system and that's where we
think dengue virus comes in this is
crazy
yeah our entire hypothesis is literally
the exact opposite of every other
biotech out there everybody else wants
to finesse the problem mm-hmm and we
totally welcome that we think that they
should yeah yeah but we're saying let's
see if we can shortcut the entire
process and brute force the immune
system is dead yeah now so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna inject cancer
patients with the dengue virus and we
have a strain of our three intravenous
correct yeah before we bash like a
couple days before
yeah like basically five days beforehand
sir so the process is this you know
before the treatment begins we'll give
the patient you know the dendritic cell
making process we take there's their
blood and their dendritic cells out you
give us we a week to two weeks we make
the product the patient is ready to come
into the clinic or to the hospital we
inject them full of the dengue they'll
be basically incubating on that for
about five days right when they develop
fever symptoms that's when we infuse
that and Hritik cells in and the reason
for that is because basically when you
get sick with a dengue fever your body's
going to go into a very very high
activation status but how do you know
that
dange gay puts the body into extreme
immune activation status versus when I
just have the flu and my body is trying
to combat the flu glad you asked
we've analyzed every single pathogen
every single virus every single bacteria
every single other immunostimulant under
the Sun and we've run experiments on our
own thank you virus data and we've
compared it to other data in the
literature I can't believe you did that
for less than 1.3 million dollars oh
yeah that's a separate aside is the FDA
stage spending 1.3 million dollars you
analyze all of that with with all these
pathogen islands we didn't have to run
too many experiments fortunately we're
in our
dengue experiments and then we compared
it to what was already published in the
literature for other pathogens or other
pathogens and other viruses okay and so
on and so so what's the percentage
increase for dengue where for your
body's gossip I mean we've analyzed it
for example two examples that we'd
compare against would be you know like
herpes and vaccinia viruses which are
two of the other viruses currently used
as on coletek and virus agents for an
anti-cancer purposes okay and what
you'll find is that you know their
cytokine profile cytokine is referring
to blood proteins or you know like
proteins in your body there are subtle
kind profiles which act as basically
immune signals for your cells their
profiles are very much like a mixed
signal a mixed bag kind of an approach
where some of their saddle kind is
induced by those viruses are
immunostimulatory and some of the other
cytokines are immunosuppressive so you
kind of have a push-pull effect when you
have those other viruses involved but
not dengue dengue makes everything go
into crazy haywire activation status and
the trick for us is actually more a
matter of safety and to me patient
safety is the most important yeah right
our strain of dengue is coming from the
time period that really doesn't even
from a bygone era in the 1980s you can't
even find the strain of dengue anymore
it was isolated in Puerto Rico before
the more virulent stinky streams
overtook it uh-huh
so the interesting thing is that we
actually have data from the CDC and from
the World Health Organization supporting
the notion that our strain of virus is
very very mild yeah
I shouldn't say mild but you know later
from a pure medical perspective there's
certain terminologies you're supposed to
use but it's more on the lower viremic
meaning in fact hippety levels okay
compared to other you know hotter
strains of dengue from let's suppose
Vietnam or Thailand okay so this is a
it's a it's a it's a kick for the immune
system into haywire but it's a mild more
of a mild kick yeah okay and then what
so then though the study a data let me
just finish I'm a go ahead I'll never
forget this
we ran our preclinical experiments using
basically taking the dengue virus that
we have and infecting human white blood
cells with it so which is exactly the
infection process that you would expect
in a human when a mosquito bites you and
you get the dengue fever right so we did
that and then we measured you know like
basically control groups unstimulated
immune cells and stimulated due to
dengue immune cells and then we put them
on top of various different tumor cell
types you know we had two different
melanoma skin cancer cell lines okay
we used a triple negative breast cancer
cell line which is known to be very very
difficult to kill and we also had a lung
cancer cell line that's also known to be
very difficult to kill and what we found
consistently across the five or six
different experiments we ran on these
with dengue is that anywhere where the
dengue stimulated the T cell or the
natural killer cell which is a different
axis of the immune system by the way and
we'll talk about that later
the market increase in ability to kill
the tumors was something between like 2x
to like 20x more than the control groups
in the same four to ten hour periods and
I remember wow that's that's a big
increase for a short time yeah so
basically you just put a t-cell a
regular t-cell or a natural killer cell
on these tumors and you see how much
does it kill you and then you put the
dengue stimulated to you cells or
natural killer cells on these tumors and
then you see how much those kill and
those greatly overshadowed the ones that
were unstimulated so we know that dengue
has this immunostimulatory effect I'm
not just the T cells but also on the
natural killer cells and you know just
by way of context in the industry you
know you have what's called the innate
immune system and the adaptive immune
system your body has both and the the
innate immune system is much more
primitive remember that when I was
flicking my arm earlier and everything
got all red and bruised
that's your innate immune system
responding immediately your natural
killer cells and other types of cells go
there pretty much like on a very very
rapid basis and find what's going on and
just kill something
they do it indiscriminately they do it
based on you know like for example if
you're can't if your cell has no ID you
know no antigen presentation the natural
killer cell just kills it directly like
that t-cells are adaptive they're on the
adaptive side of the immune system which
is much more smarts much more
intelligence driven much more where the
dendritic cells interact with the
t-cells than the t-cells pick up the
info and then they go back and kill the
cancer cell they take a little bit
longer to work so the neat thing for us
is that dengue does both of the adaptive
and the innate arms at the same time
which not a lot of other like products
do in fact I couldn't find any other
ones in the literature that hit on both
at the same time with a well-established
understood safety profile the way that
dengue has and that's what God is
excited and I'll never forget this point
after we finished that experiment there
was another third arm of that entire
trial or that experiment design in which
we took the dengue virus proteins that
came out of the human blood after the
human bullet was infected and no t-cells
no natural killer cells no you know like
effector cells that are meant to kill
right
no stim you know stimulation and we just
put the proteins directly on top of
tumor cells and that killed a bunch of
the tumor cells directly as well so we
didn't really quite understand what that
meant initially but I'll never forget
this dr. Bernie Fox a PhD one of the
foremost experts in cancer immunotherapy
past president of set C the Society for
immunotherapy and cancer and acting as
an ambassador for tzitzit now you know
he's on our science advisory board he
looked at that data and he I remember
this here at Lehman close to me he put
his arm and hand on my arm like this he
looked me dead in the eye like head on
and he said Tony this direct apoptosis
arm you know what this means and I said
uh it means that the immune system that
this thing kills it kind of like what a
t-cell does he goes yes but it means and
works like a drug you doesn't work just
like a virus you have something here
yeah that's the clinical trials as soon
as you can yeah yeah and when he said
that in the context of all the other
greats t-cell stimulation that we saw in
the great NK cell natural killer cell
stimulation that we saw and this third
direct cell death inducing arm of it
we said oh my gosh we are onto something
that literally no one else is doing to
do this yeah so dengue acts like a drug
as well as virus yes so it can be
administered in its mild mist forms that
have been isolated in the past was good
they did that absolutely and now you can
replicate that and then and then use it
as a drug that's so interesting because
people typically don't think about that
kind of stuff so hopefully this works
out because this seems like a big
advancement
I'm glad you you know I'm glad you
pulled that pulled me over for that
because it was real intimate moments
yeah it's good to feel that to really
you know if I feel that moment of the
story yeah so okay so now so now I go
through hopefully in the future you'll
take a blood sample in a biopsy sample
and preferably at a early stage cancer
it's time and then and maybe even one
day even pre cancer just in general I
can administer dengue as a drug to
combat other types of malevolence
activities going on within my body as a
pathology who knows what who would it
could be used for down the line yeah but
but boom hopefully we can and do get you
through clinical trials and get through
out into the world yeah yeah so much you
know the funny thing that you mentioned
about that doctor Franco Marin Cola who
is also a former president of City and
one of the the foremost experts on genes
and cancer immunotherapy he wrote
literally the textbook on cancer I I
have the textbook it is you know written
with him and and the current president
of set C um he's actually really
interested in dengue not just as an
amino stimulant for cancer purposes
which i think is you know very
very good as an opening hypothesis for
us but because dengue has this wide
immune response along both the innate
and the adaptive immune system
he saw that immediately as a means of
combating many many other diseases in
the future does any things that you know
from an immuno stimulation perspective
there's so much good things happening
yeah fro immuno stimulation that you
want to just try this out on a whole
bunch of other stuff as well exactly and
to your point we do want to go much
earlier stage in the cancer patient
journey we want to go before they
received an standard of care ideally you
know in the very very long run the
vision for us is to turn this into a
prophylactic vaccine and that's you know
part of us building out the clinical
trial data sets and justifying the
safety to be able to go earlier and
earlier in time of course and dropping
the cost curves down as part of the drug
development process of course Thanks so
we the tip of the spear is late stage
cancer and then the spear spreads wider
and we go into all these other different
directions once we get some early good
data yeah yep so that's what we're gonna
do man hell yeah prime VAX three years
in less than years but like less than
one and a half million bucks on on
getting to clinical trials that's a big
deal that's tough to do so
congratulations thanks so much so okay
so that's prime vachs
now maybe we ask you some
thought-provoking questions about the
about from our show but also balance
with the industry very specific to you
that I think maybe you'll find you'll
find interesting what do you think about
the ethics of genetic engineering for
example let's do let's do genetic
engineering intelligence or metabolism
augmentations and how those will be very
available to people that have more money
up front yeah what do you think about
that in general it's an ethical
consideration I don't think from so my
take as a drug industry guy and as
someone who you know came from Pharma
and biotech I would say is that you know
what like that's just healthy industry
works you have to allow the early
adopters with any sort of a new
technology iPhones you know laptops the
internet right the early adopters are
the ones who remote
gungho most excited and we're willing to
pay the money to actually do it okay
degenerate Oskar will drop down exactly
but so what do you think about the
ethics in general of you being able to
genetically engineer whatever you want
on yourself or potentially do some bio
warfare what do you think about this
should there be controlled experiments
or Studies on the health effects on one
person over time yeah absolutely so um
the FDA already has a very very
well-established process for new drugs
going through development for which you
know CRISPR talyn's all these new
technologies that are coming out for
gene editing will need to abide by and
we know that they will need to abide by
those rules because there were companies
who are trying to skirt the line there
was one out in San Diego recently I read
on the news maybe half a year ago in
which they were trying to basically
justify the notion that you know like
their drug or their treatment process
did not follow FDA requirements for what
constitutes a clinical trial so
therefore they did not need to go
through the FDA process
well they got slapped down very very
hard to a cease and desist letter in
process yeah exactly I mean like the FDA
shut them down made them go through the
entire rigmarole and honestly you know
they pissed a bunch of people off in the
FDA and you do not want to piss people
off because agency won't succeed with
you can't push through yeah and for
better or worse you know that I think
this is another question that people
tend to ask you know like well the US
FDA is too strict you know like they
don't do things that um what's the right
amount of regulating except enables
innovation yeah absolutely and what do
you think some people will go to Brazil
or other countries where the regulations
are more lacks right and they'll get
their treatment I think that for better
or worse the US FDA is the best standard
of high quality data
yeah and quality you know ruling in
these types of spaces yeah and I say
that honestly because all you have to do
is look at every other country that has
an established health care system all
the European countries Japan even China
you know like Australia
you know Canada you know all these
places right they all defer to the FDA
in the US on drug quality and they
actually generally accept more US data
going from the u.s. to those other
countries than the other way around
yeah meaning if I run the clinical trial
in Italy yeah I try to bring that data
into the US the US FDA may not accept it
you have to run another one maybe here
yeah exactly but conversely the opposite
direction much easier exactly
so then how about how do we work
together across the world especially
what are your thoughts about about the
way that other countries like China are
putting a lot of attention on figuring
out how to you know how to work on
fixing pathology on yeah I'm living
longer on living healthier how do you
how do we work together but also still
foster innovation with this movement for
globalization yeah so I just speaking of
China I just learned this recently
apparently all amino oncology clinical
trials are halted in China as of like a
month or two ago with the exception of
one specific region in like the Hainan
district and the interesting thing is
that actually the the Chinese government
says you know what there have been too
many drugs
going through the clinical trial process
here in China there's ten pd1 drugs that
were already approved there I forget if
it's pd-1 or Carr teas I want to say
it's PD one don't quote me on that but
many many new drugs have been already
approved in China and the Chinese
government said you know what this is
too much for us to handle we're just
gonna do a blank slate shut everything
down except in this special region and
in this special region as long as you
meet the bare minimum requirements you
can run whatever clinical trial you want
this just happened in the last couple of
months okay so what was the reason why
again because in these other regions too
much oversights needed from the Chinese
FDA and then they just said only in this
one region we'll put all of our
oversight and then everybody goes to
that one really exactly and then you
have a much more standardized pathway
there and then so that became their FDA
exactly exactly so there but that
regulation doesn't apply
in the u.s. at all right we go through a
big process where you know you could
pick your clinical trial site throughout
the country you get that written up into
a protocol and then you submit that to
the FDA right that's the process but in
China they're just saying yep the
special region and that's it so the
interesting thing I would say to answer
your question how do we work together
with them we as biotech companies if you
were to actually take the industry view
on it which is you know like most of the
pharma companies of the Mercs the
Amgen's the Genentech's of the world and
you ask them you know like do you want
to get into China they'll say actually
no like I don't want you it's kind of a
kind of a dumpy market you know it's
it's hard to get into you have to know
all these different special connections
and everything else in order to get
anything done in China but the
interesting thing is that you know with
this new special program I think it's
the onus is on us as the industry to
actually be more open-minded about this
type of stuff definitely because I
across the world absolutely yeah to work
together with all the brilliant people
oh for sure man yeah I mean because all
of a sudden if other countries in the
world know about dengue then maybe they
can be like well what other things exist
like that in the world that can be used
as a drug we want everybody else to be
doing that entire process we want to
foster that level of imitation because
if people are imitating you you're doing
something right yeah yeah that's how I
think about it right so absolutely we
want that we want to share the data we
want to be you know like a very very
transparent organization to everybody
else you know like the FDA hospitals
doctors but most importantly the public
and the truth is you know I think from
my perspective I don't think that the
pharma and the biotech industry have
done a very good job of actually being
consumer friendly like I think a lot of
people out there in the world view the
pharma and the biotech industry as this
big giant monolithic you know like black
box for which you know they're hiding
you know for example the cure for cancer
tucked away somewhere in their back
pockets or in their laboratory somewhere
and they're just building drugs that are
meant to sustain your life a little bit
more and more and more
and and we'll never actually know yeah I
mean I don't think we will but because
if you have a trillion dollars you can
basically do whatever you want with your
health you can probably even live
forever at this point you would think so
yeah I think my personal view on that is
that you know there are gonna be certain
limitations to human biology and they're
also going to be certain limitations to
how much we can actually control
everything but that's you know part of
the that's part of Susan that won't be
the case oh absolutely yeah but that's
part of the game that the you know the
smart you know finesse biotech people
are doing right we want them to be going
after CRISPR to build all those things
out to do all the gene editing you know
be very very laser focused on editing
your T cells for example and then just
curing disease from the ground up we
want that for sure let's let's let's end
on a couple questions yeah how about
Tony do you think that were alone in the
cosmos oh man I really really hope that
we're not yy-you want some friends out
there I think we do I mean you know the
truth it would be a very very lonely
existence if we were the only planet
circling the only Sun that happens to
harbor you know life right and I want
that contact you look at Star Wars Star
Trek Starship Troopers pick any of those
science-fiction things with the star
phrase in front why do you want the
contact because I think it would be
interesting I think it would be honestly
it would be something more more than
what we have now exactly you know what I
feel like it would it would instill a
finally a sense of tribalism across the
planet final absolutely man do you think
that we're in a computer simulation you
know I thought about this long and hard
I mean your show is called the
simulation series right so the the
political answer is absolutely yes we're
in a simulation but now the my own
personal feeling on it is that honestly
speaking if we're in a simulation we're
in a good enough one that the rules are
actually pretty well understood
absolutely and if you you know if I come
at you and I punch you in the face your
face is going to get bruised up yeah
that's just that those are the rules of
the
there's another rule would you thing you
give to jail it's exactly yeah exactly
so usually you know exactly what the
sequence of actions or events are going
to be how you do these things right no
your next algorithm is to eat food and
drink water and use the bathroom
absolutely your heart beats against
needs we process oxygen we take in
oxygen we pump out carbon dioxide plants
are the exact opposite right you break
those rules you die so really I don't
really care if we're in a simulation or
not I think we're in one but you know it
doesn't really change the fact that you
know we have a lot of stuff that we need
to do today you know change the life
yeah i-i've in prosper by lutely the
rules are very fascinating the
programming language was very
fascinating and what's really
interesting is that the programming
language changes based on the mass of
the planet at the proximity to the star
you know the carbon-based life forms
there are other DNA coding life forms
that have prospered at what you're
traveling all that stuff yeah absolutely
it also changes when you figure the game
out they [ __ ] it all up and change it I
just want to throw that in there
simulation every single time that you
will learn more about the programming
the programming changes that's right the
programming changes a bit yeah
top-secret information right yeah I'm
gonna get in trouble just for saying
that
okay how about Tony alright how about
how about last question how about what
do you think it's the most beautiful
thing in the world oh man
the most beautiful thing in the world
probably the notion of earned happiness
and I'm a big proponent of that I think
that a lot of for I think first of all
beauty is obviously you know defined
based on whoever is the observer right
but I think there are some universal
constants that you can generally agree
on as people one example being that you
know like people generally haven't like
this innate drive to do something to
achieve you know self-actualization
right according to you know like you
know the Maslow's pyramid of hierarchy
and all that stuff right and I think at
the very very top self-actualization
really comes down to earned happiness
and when I say aren't happiness what I
mean by that is you have a very clear
goal in mind you know exactly why you're
accomplishing that goal you do
everything in your power to make that
goal happen and then you see it you
bring it into reality that for a lot of
people doesn't happen often some people
never get that feeling in the world
throughout their entire existence and
honestly like that's what I'm chasing
after man to me that's the most I think
yeah you do that that is a natural high
you will always feel that you will
always know that you did that you earned
it nothing no one can ever take that
away from you and I think that's the
most beautiful thing in the world that's
beautiful and really well said that
self-actualization this earned happiness
this this journey this Hustle through
this journey of what what maximizes my
thriving my feeling most alive and then
how if that also core has some sort of
corollary with bringing value to the
world at the same time oh man that's
just a dead there's no regrets then
absolutely I was a mobile life with no
regrets
totally no fear totally just absolutely
this is the right thing makes sense no
internal inconsistencies you know that's
yeah all about yeah yeah and hustling in
that direction is that no internal
inconsistencies a lot it's really good
that as well said I love it
Tony Tony Chen thank you so much prime
VAX thank you so much Ellen it's a
pleasure yeah awesome job awesome job
with the company thanks for explaining
this so relatedly on the show bringing
us down to a way of understanding our
bodies and understanding cancer
understanding immunotherapy
understanding all the possible futures
all these processes that exist in
getting there so thank you very much and
this has been a pleasure let's let's get
famous keep these conversations out to
more people let's get them fired to have
them change the world doing the world
baby thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate you please share this
content with other people around you
let's get more people inspired talking
about this like comment we'd love to
hear from you
if you haven't yet hit that subscribe
button gently press it we'd love for you
to join us smash it whatever or smash it
we say that sometimes as well thank you
for supporting us on patreon we need to
keep the studio thriving keep the lights
on electricity going all that stuff so
please do join us on patreon that helps
a lot thanks to our partner producer Ron
Fergus our partner Pat our photographer
Lisa Cinelli
thank you so much everybody and we'll
catch you again soon peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]